charlie what is going on how can i help
so i'm kind of
putting myself back out in the dating
scene and i've been with this
guy for i don't know let's say a month
now hold on
so before that so you said you're going
back to the dating scene were you in a
long-term thing
well it was five years ago that i was in
a relationship and that relations kind
of ruined me and so
i just kind of took time to take care of
myself wait hold on
what do you mean it ruined you i don't
like that language that makes me like ah
you're not ruined you're awesome
why would it why did it ruin you um
i guess i it just didn't leave me in
in the best version of myself and i
didn't like who i was after i left
man you were being cryptic charlie help
me out so
what do you mean um well he he cheated
on me
and then um i was emotionally invested
and i was heartbroken when i found out
and so um yeah i went i was
depressed for a little while maybe like
i would say like two years or something
but then
i came out of it and now i think i'm
ready to be in the dating scene again i
think
i think um but i've been with this guy
for a month
and i just feel a little bit like i'm
like suffocating a little now
with him i think maybe because i've just
been so used to being alone and
independent and
doing things in my own time and so i'm
sort of just wondering how i can
gently let him know that i'm feeling
just a little bit suffocated
yeah and charlie there's a lot here and
i don't even know that you know there's
a lot here
um
james how much time we got we have a
four or five hours we can sit down and
talk through this
probably not nope okay so
oh man okay let me ask you a few more
questions charlie
okay so five five years ago y'all broke
up or y'all were together for five years
and then you found some stuff out about
him he was cheating on you
and you were all in invested and it just
rattled you to your core
and you didn't like some things about
you i'm just gonna infer
maybe you made some you made some
behavioral decisions you did some things
that you're like man that's not stopped
me
or you reacted in some ways it's just
not me um
and now you're coming out of it and
you're ready to get back into it and
you're back into it
and you're like oh this this is not the
dude is that where we're at
yeah i think so kind of so give me an
example of something when you say it
just wasn't me
what did you do that you look back and
go oh
geez louise that was not me um
but it was you but that's not me but it
was you but you know what i mean
yeah i think i think one
one major difference after that is i
just noticed that
um i kept to myself a lot more i'm
usually a person that like likes to go
out and
interact with people and meet new people
and so after that i was just
home a lot um sitting in the corner of a
room
oh man okay yeah and yeah and that was
just pretty much it and my closest
friends and family um they noticed that
and they pulled me out of it
gracefully and so i think i'm in a good
spot now and with this
new guy um i want to give the good parts
of me to him but then
i'm just a little bit afraid maybe that
because he's so good to me that
it's just too good to be i know it's
good to be true maybe
okay so that was gonna be my first
question is this dude just lane
no he's he's amazing actually he's
really good um
he he's vulnerable with his feelings
which is something that i was looking
for
um he he makes me a priority which is
not nothing i've ever had before um and
he's just
he's just overall good and so i don't i
don't know if
i'm actually feeling suffocated or if
i'm just worried that i'm gonna
become emotionally invested again and
then yeah
okay so that's now it's much now i've
got a more
a much clearer picture okay okay
so i'm gonna tell you a couple things
about your heart
and your brain that is hopefully will
give you some peace
okay okay number one
you got hurt bad is that right yeah
it was pretty fast okay so i want you to
know that it's brave that you even say
that out loud good for you
okay you got you got roasted you got
burned
okay and that hurts and when we get hurt
then our brain remembers that pain
especially deep violations
of connected relationships it's why
childhood trauma when parents abuse
their kids or parents neglect their kids
that trauma stays with us forever unless
we do some hard
hard work because our brain remembers i
ain't ever gonna hurt like that again
right and so if this is a guy how old
are you
i'm 25. okay so this dude you're with
for five years you had plans with him
huh
i did you were you were looking at
furniture in your mind
for not even the first house but the
second house right
yeah naming kids and things like that
okay so
that hurt bad right and it wasn't just a
breakup hurt but it was a violation hurt
and your brain notched that and said
all right that's never happening again
because your brain's job is not to make
sure you are happy
and that there are snowflakes and
rainbows everywhere
it's to make sure you're alive right
and so every time from this point
forward for a season when you start
getting close
and it recognizes oh crap she's falling
in love it's gonna sound the alarms
okay okay because it's assuming hey you
forgot
what happened last time genius we're not
doing this again right
so every time you feel that
that suffocation feeling that tightness
in your chest that ah
that it's too good to be true that just
smile and understand that your brain's
just trying to take care of you
okay it's just trying to love you the
best way it knows how and our brains are
sometimes really incredible and
sometimes they're blunt instruments okay
okay and sometimes you may even need to
go hey thank you for taking care of me
i've got it
i appreciate you okay here's the second
thing
when you are when people get cheated on
especially
in a long-term relationship there's the
the obvious pain i lost this
relationship there's the pain of
betrayal
sometimes people often people stay
together and
they have to learn how to love again got
to learn how to trust again
and it look they have to build something
new what people
often don't talk about in when someone
gets cheated on when someone
betrays somebody else like this is that
you
lose trust in yourself
you lose trust in charlie's judgment
because you didn't see this coming
you were all in had you known had you
seen this coming you would have
protected yourself and you missed it
right that and and i'm not saying this
is your fault i'm just saying here's the
narrative that goes in our minds
how could i have not seen that and then
you may even start
rewinding the history of your
relationship and you start realizing i
did know
i saw that i didn't want to see it i saw
that i saw him hide his phone i saw this
i saw that
and i i blocked it out of my mind i
didn't want to see it
and then you start beating yourself up
but there's this loss of trust in
yourself
right and you sound like someone who is
super lucky that
you not lucky you've worked hard to
cultivate awesome friends around you is
that right you got a good you got a good
squad that runs with you yes they always
tell me straight up what's wrong
oh that's so good man um yeah you're
that's a that's a gift
that man nurture that nurture that
forever friends or
everything um but here's what you have
to do you have to learn to trust
yourself again
and you only can learn to do that by
practicing right by leaning into those
really uncomfortable moments and so
here's the hard truth i'm going to give
you you ready
yeah i'm ready this guy may be
incredible
you may have had a disastrous
heartbreaking relationship
and you may be ready to get back on on
on the horse or back in the wagon i
don't know any non-west texas references
here back on the
on the harley i don't know what i don't
know what happens in indianapolis but
whatever
um but you may be ready to get back on
and then your first
the first the first rattle out of the
bag the first game he's the one
right you're 25 you found him and it's
gonna be it forever
or charlie he may cheat on you
he may suck and here's what i'm telling
you that i'm not telling that to be mean
i'm telling you this
all relationships a hundred percent of
them
are a risk
they're a risk they're scary and
that's what makes them hard and that's
what makes them so
incredibly important for us and so
you're gonna have to lean into that risk
you're gonna have to lean into that
unknown you're gonna have to let your
brain know hey
i know this could happen again i'm gonna
walk
i'm gonna take the lessons that i
learned last time i'm gonna be open and
vulnerable with this new guy
and he turns out he's a dweeb he's a
dork man then i'm out
right and listen to your body if you're
like dude you're suffocating me man quit
texting me weirdo
then tell him that right you can tell
him okay
if you start thinking this guy's
incredible
i'm not ready yet let him know that
and you don't have to be ready you know
whose timetable you're on
nobody's just yours okay
okay there's no rules to this deal other
than you
be honest and vulnerable and you be true
to yourself
and then what however you move forward
is however you move forward
okay you my new sister charlie
are in full full control okay of the
story of the narrative of the potential
of getting hurt again
and the potential of being loved
and loved and loved and loved
and love is a risk and it's hard and
it's scary and it's so so good
what do you think um
no crying on my show charlie just
kidding
i'm crying tears of um a good
confirmation
because i think i've i know i know all
that and it's just good to hear from
someone else
that that isn't in my circle that that
maybe i'm just not lying to myself or
fooling myself
because these people just want to please
me or who i
am but i appreciate that
hey listen i appreciate you for being
brave i appreciate you for being bold
and for listening to your body
and not ignoring your heart and also not
being afraid to push through when it
gets real scary
and listen you know who needs to hear
this
this guy yeah
does he know that that you were in a
five-year relationship and that
guy cheated on you and things got messy
and you got your heart broken does he
know this
no he doesn't yeah so maybe maybe you'd
be vulnerable at some point let him know
okay i want you like you know what i
mean think of it this way if one time
you were
training for a marathon and you stepped
off the curb accidentally and broke your
ankle
and then you went through you just spent
a season not running because you got to
let your leg heal and then you went to
rehab
and then you started jogging around the
block and then you joined a runner's
group
you'd probably let them know hey listen
i'm gonna do the best i can with what
i've got i've got to get back in shape
this whole thing's new and i don't trust
my new leg yet
my rehabbed ankle yet i'm gonna have to
build some trust in it
and some people in that group are like
well forget you bro i'm taking off i'm
getting my super marathon time
but a big chunk of that group would be
like sweet you run with us
right okay and it's just learning to
step on that on that ankle
until you know it's strong you know it's
good and you've got good friends i can
tell on the phone you've got a
like a indianapolis sized heart i don't
even know how big that is i was going to
say texas-sized heart but
i don't know you that well but you have
an indianapolis-sized heart
you're made of gold and somebody's gonna
be lucky to to have you in their life
and it's okay to go slow okay
and i'll tell you this you have blessed
me today charlie um
i appreciate you calling and being
vulnerable and
um trust your heart and trust your body
trust your friends and most importantly
trust
you